esto que estáis viendo aquí es la
constitución de venezuela aquí hay
muchas de las claves para entender lo
que está pasando en este país y lo que
es más importante porque no podemos
hablar de un golpe de estado en
venezuela en este vídeo te lo vamos a
explicar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay muchas formas de derrocar a un
dictador revoluciones transiciones
pacíficas pero al menos que yo recuerde
no hay ningún caso en el que un líder
jura el cargo para deponer a un gobierno
autoritario porque dejemos las cosas
claras desde el primer momento lo que
hay en venezuela es una dictadura la
dictadura de nicolás maduro
[Música]
y si ya sé lo que me vais a decir muchos
fonseca en venezuela hay elecciones por
supuesto que las hay también hay
elecciones en bangladesh egipto o
azerbaiyán incluso en corea del norte
tienen elecciones legislativas cada 5
años y hay distintos partidos políticos
tal cual como lo oís sin embargo una
democracia necesita elecciones libres
limpias y libertad de expresión y si
recordáis en este vídeo ya os
explicábamos como la libertad de
expresión es tan escasa en venezuela
como el papel higiénico
y si ya sé que pese a la crisis
humanitaria la violencia y las
constantes violaciones de derechos
humanos
nicolás maduró todavía cuenta con un
enorme apoyo popular por supuesto que
esto es verdad la lección número uno del
manual de todo dictador consiste en
ganarte el apoyo de la mayoría con
enormes campañas de propaganda y por
supuesto la lección número 2 dice que a
cualquiera que te plante cara le tienes
que meter en la cárcel cuando controlas
el poder judicial legislativo es muy
fácil acusar a un opositor de cualquier
delito en el caso de las monarquías
árabes a los opositores se les acusa de
estar conectados con el terrorismo y en
el caso de venezuela se les acusa de
golpistas
[Música]
y ahora estaréis pensando vale puede que
nicolás maduró sea un dictador pero juan
guaidó ha dado un golpe de estado a fin
de cuentas se ha proclamado como
presidente del gobierno sin ganar unas
elecciones presidenciales verdad pues
tampoco veréis un golpe de estado se
define como una toma del gobierno
mediante el uso de la fuerza por parte
de un grupo que ostenta el poder dentro
del propio gobierno
normalmente el ejército sin embargo juan
guaidó sea proclamado presidente a
través de un artículo previsto en la
constitución de venezuela el artículo
233 permite que el presidente de la
asamblea nacional ocupe temporalmente la
presidencia de la república
[Música]
es decir el líder del legislativo se
encarga de la jefatura del estado y del
ejecutivo venezolano hasta que se
realicen nuevas elecciones en menos de
30 días así que quien está respetando
escrupulosamente la constitución es la
oposición no nicolás maduro
ahora bien la pregunta que si nos
podemos hacer es esto que está pasando
en venezuela es bueno o es malo de
verdad es tan sencillo acabar con una
dictadura basta con proclamar a otro
presidente que los reconozcan distintos
países y ya está pues mis queridos
amigos de visual política nada más lejos
de la realidad por supuesto que nos
encantaría poder descorchar el champán
con vosotros sabemos que muchos
venezolanos veis nuestro canal
muchos nos habéis pedido por mensajes
que hagamos este vídeo y sé que queréis
una buena dosis de optimismo pero a
veces en política tenemos que dejar las
pasiones a un lado y ver las cosas con
frialdad más que nada porque estamos
hablando de la vida de casi 30 millones
de personas
[Música]
y si algo hemos aprendido de la historia
es que todo puede ir a peor el final
violento de muchas dictaduras ha llevado
a una guerra civil que ha dejado el país
mucho peor de lo que estaba ahí está el
irak de sadam husein o la libia de
gadafi es esto lo que va a pasar en
venezuela hay razones para ser
optimistas con venezuela hoy no vamos a
responder a estas preguntas porque es
imposible pero sí vamos a daros unas
claves para que podáis formarnos
vuestras propias conclusiones con más
rigor y para eso como siempre antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
el fin de la democracia quedaos con esta
fecha 1 de mayo de 2017 en ese momento
el parlamento de venezuela tenía una
mayoría anti nicolás maduro por supuesto
que no hablamos de un único partido que
se opone al gobierno en realidad los
opositores a maduro van desde la derecha
hasta la izquierda pero eso poco importa
desde que arrancó 2016 el parlamento
había sido declarado en desacato y os
preguntaréis qué gran delito había
cometido la asamblea nacional pues
resulta que la causa del desacato fue a
aceptar la participación de tres
diputados de la oposición denunciados
por el chavismo
porque fueron denunciados pues ni más ni
menos que porque eran los necesarios por
la oposición para confirmar una mayoría
de dos tercios los dos tercios suponen
lo que podríamos llamar una supermayoría
suficiente como para poder bloquear a
maduro pero como el pueblo había elegido
a la oposición
maduro movió los resortes para anular su
poder no convocó el poder constituyente
originario
para lograr la paz que necesita la
república para derrotar el golpe
fascista y para que sea el pueblo con su
soberanía quien imponga la paz la
armonía el diálogo nacional verdadero
en ese momento maduro declaraba ilegal
al parlamento del país la llamada
asamblea nacional es decir anulaba el
poder legislativo el único órgano que
podía hacerle oposición perdió todo su
poder y que ocurrió después pues
básicamente maduro se inventó un nuevo
parlamento la llamada asamblea nacional
constituyente según el artículo 348 de
la constitución venezolana maduro puede
convocar una asamblea constituyente el
objetivo de esta asamblea no es otro que
redactar una constitución nueva para el
país el problema pues que esa asamblea
nacional constituyente de maduro se ha
convertido en un parlamento paralelo
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea han llegado
a probar hasta leyes que regulan los
impuestos ya me diréis qué tiene que ver
eso con la constitución de un país pero
no sólo eso veréis de los 545 diputados
que tiene esta asamblea nacional
constituyente 503 pertenecen al partido
de maduro tal cual como lo es el resto
son cargos vacantes es decir que se
trata de un parlamento donde todos los
miembros son de la misma formación y os
preguntaréis qué pasa con el parlamento
antiguo el que tenía distintos partidos
políticos pues se siguen reuniendo pero
sin ningún poder político a fin de
cuentas quien cuenta con el ejército y
con la policía para hacer cumplir la ley
es nicolás maduro y la asamblea nacional
constituyente
[Música]
pero aquí no termina la historia en 2018
esta asamblea nacional constituyente
donde todos sus miembros son del mismo
partido convoca unas elecciones
presidenciales elecciones donde la
mayoría de partidos no pueden
presentarse porque son ilegales y que
tienen más trampas que una escopeta de
feria tanto es así que el 60% el 60 por
ciento de los votantes inscritos se
abstienen de ir a votar como os podéis
imaginar el resultado de estas
elecciones fue tan predecible como el
final de la pasión de cristo' maduro
arrasó pero casi ningún país reconoció
el resultado habéis oído bien es decir
ya en mayo del año 2018
mike pence el vicepresidente de los eeuu
decía lo siguiente
eeuu llaman estas elecciones por su
nombre son una impostura maduro debe
organizar elecciones libres y limpias y
liberar a todos los presos políticos
inmediatamente y sin condiciones
mike pence vicepresidente de los eeuu y
lo mismo pasó con alemania colombia
costa rica y por supuesto españa nadie
reconoció la legitimidad de maduro para
ser el presidente de venezuela el
problema pues y no había otra
alternativa y aquí es cuando llegamos a
enero de 2019 en este momento nicolás
maduro jura su cargo pero no lo hace
ante la asamblea nacional sino ante el
tribunal supremo y ahí es cuando ha
acabado el primer mandato de maduro con
una jura inconstitucional para iniciar
su segundo mandato es cuando el
presidente del parlamento venezolano
juan guaidó se proclama presidente ante
el vacío de poder que se ha generado
porque pues bueno porque representa al
único órgano que todavía tiene
legitimidad democrática en el país
[Música]
y en ese momento es cuando todos los
países que no habían reconocido las
elecciones presidenciales que ganó
maduro pasan a reconocer a why do como
presidente legítimo de venezuela eso
incluye a estados unidos canadá y muy
probablemente la unión europea pero ya
sé lo que estáis pensando muchos y si
todo esto fuera un movimiento orquestado
desde washington a fin de cuentas cinco
minutos después de que why do saliera
nombrado presidente interino ya contaba
con las bendiciones de washington
parece demasiada casualidad verdad pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
a quién le importa venezuela si seguís
visual política desde hace tiempo ya lo
sabéis muy bien venezuela es el país con
las mayores reservas de petróleo del
mundo mucho más que árabe saudita rusia
o eeuu
el problema que apenas son capaces de
vender lo veréis una cosa es tener humo
de dinosaurio y otra muy distinta es
poder ganar dinero cuando lo vendes
fijaos en esta gráfica
aquí se puede ver lo que cuesta sacar un
barril de crudo en distintos países
arabia saudita tiene el barril más
barato por eso da igual el precio de
mercado del petróleo ellos siempre sacan
beneficios sin embargo venezuela está en
el otro lado es uno de los petróleos más
caros del mundo
la empresa que lo extrae de devesa es un
auténtico caos en otras palabras a duras
penas son capaz de reproducir crudo para
que les salga rentable con el precio
actual del mercado internacional para
que os hagáis una idea aunque venezuela
sea el país con más reservas de crudo
del mundo producen menos que angola o
nigeria es más venezuela solamente
supone un 7 por ciento de las
importaciones de crudo de eeuu en otras
palabras que por mucho petróleo que
tenga venezuela su peso específico en la
economía mundial es más bien poco
especialmente en un momento donde
gracias al fracking todo hijo de vecino
se pone a vender zumo de dinosaurio por
otra parte trump ya se ha encargado de
restringir las inversiones a venezuela
es decir que los intereses que puedan
tener los bancos estadounidenses en
posicionarse de un lado u otra de la
balanza son más bien pocos
y si es cierto que trump ha nombrado a
elliot abrams para gestionar todos los
asuntos con venezuela- abrams colaboró
en el intento de golpe de estado contra
chávez en 2002 pero seamos honestos el
principio no parece que eeuu esté
demasiado preocupado por venezuela ni
siquiera por motivos de propaganda por
ejemplo si miráis la portada online de
un periódico español como el país.com o
el confidencial veréis muchas noticias
dedicadas a venezuela está claro que es
un tema que nos importa los que hablamos
en español pero llama la atención que la
prensa angloparlante apenas ha dedicado
un par de noticias está por ejemplo es
la portada de la foreign affairs que tal
vez sea la revista más influyente de la
política de eeuu
y esta otra es la portada de la foreign
policy en fin no parece que haya
demasiado entusiasmo por venezuela en
eeuu sin embargo aquí no adivina es
quien si tiene algo que decir en el
futuro de nicolás maduro lo habéis
adivinado
[Música]
y si se queda con el 28% de la
producción de petróleo de venezuela para
repagar su deuda exacto lo que ya hemos
visto en tantos otros vídeos pagos de
deuda a cambio de materias primas china
necesita un suministrador de petróleo y
por eso ha estado prestando dinero a
maduro como si no existiera mañana
beijing le ha prestado más de 50 mil
millones de dólares a caracas para que
os hagáis una idea eso podría ser el
coste de unos tres juegos olímpicos y
como venezuela no puede pagar con dinero
pues paga con lo único que sobra en el
país zumo de dinosaurio todavía os
preguntáis por qué china no ha
reconocido agua ido exacto nicolás
maduro es el único líder político que
todavía puede garantizar el suministro
de crudo mientras que un nuevo gobierno
pues no lo sabemos a todo esto hay que
sumarle narcotráfico según informes de
la dea entre el 15 y el 20 por ciento de
la coca que se mueve cada año pasa por
venezuela grandes figuras del régimen de
maduro como diosdado cabello están
implicadas en el tráfico de drogas
ilegales
podemos decir que venezuela es hoy en
día un narcoestado un lugar donde los
traficantes pueden establecer sus
centros de operaciones con la ayuda de
las propias autoridades
vale pero todo esto está muy bien sin
embargo la gran pregunta es puede haber
de verdad una transición democrática en
venezuela pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
qué se puede hacer como decíamos antes
la oposición a venezuela se caracteriza
por una cosa la fragmentación absoluta
hablamos de montones de partidos
políticos con ideologías totalmente
dispares hay conservadores liberales e
incluso socialdemócratas a diferencia de
otros países como polonia o república
checa donde si había líderes que
aglutinaban la oposición al régimen
hasta ahora no había una alternativa
clara a maduro sin embargo todo esto
parecía haber cambiado en muy poco
tiempo con tantísimo apoyo internacional
juan guaidó sí que puede hacer frente a
maduro
por supuesto cargo oficial es el de
presidente interino y esto qué significa
pues que en cuanto sea posible debe
convocar unas elecciones es decir que
ocupa la presidencia de forma
provisional pero esperad un momento
porque esta es la única buena noticia
veréis las leyes y las buenas palabras
son muy importantes pero en última
instancia el poder lo tiene aquel con
fuerza para imponer la ley por eso
controlar a la policía y al ejército es
tan importante
en otras palabras why do puede tener
toda la legitimidad que quiera pero como
puede convocar unas elecciones si el
ejército no se lo permite qué pasa con
la policía todo esto explica por qué los
últimos días tanto maduro como guaidó
han estado intentando ganarse el apoyo
de las fuerzas de seguridad
[Música]
nicolás maduro pidió lealtad al ejército
tenemos que hacer respetar el poder de
la nación venezolana con el poder
militar por el momento el ejército
siempre se ha mantenido leal al régimen
los altos cargos del ejército venezolano
son completamente afines a maduro y eso
explica que durante los últimos años
caracas haya estado subiendo el sueldo a
sus militares año tras año para que os
hagáis una idea un soldado de raso en
este país puede cobrar bastante más que
un médico pero aún así hablamos de
alrededor de 80 dólares al mes en otras
palabras que tampoco es ninguna fortuna
es esto suficiente como para que el
ejército se sublevó contra maduro no lo
sabemos pero desde luego es importante
tenerlo en cuenta quienes sí viven mucho
mejor son los altos cargos del ejército
no me creéis pues venías conmigo de
paseo al barrio salamanca
para quienes no sabéis de españa' el
barrio salamanca es algo así como el
manhattan de madrid una de las zonas más
lujosas y céntricas de la capital en
esta zona prácticamente todo el mundo
vota a partidos conservadores y
prácticamente todo el mundo tiene una
renta media alta hace el año 2010
los únicos venezolanos que vivían por
aquí eran los miembros de la oposición
en el exilio gente como por ejemplo la
familia de henrique capriles que han
hecho varias inversiones por aquí pero
con el paso de los años han llegado más
y más chavistas tanto es así que algunos
ya empiezan a llamar el barrio salamanca
como la little venezuela
me encuentro algunas veces sentado en
restaurantes en madrid al lado de
personas a quienes no me sentiría cómodo
de ver en caracas dijo leopoldo lopez
jil padre de leopoldo lópez un líder
opositor en arresto domiciliario algunos
casos fueron tan sonados como el de la
enfermera personal de hugo chávez en
2015 comprar una casa por más de 18
millones de euros en metálico tal cual y
así otros tantos casos gente que llega
con maletines de billetes y compró
auténticos apartamentos de lujo con
precios nacho vidal ya nos por ejemplo
también se ha visto varias veces
saliendo por madrid a una de las hijas
del ministro de defensa de venezuela en
otras palabras que hay una huida de
capitales por parte de muchos oficiales
de maduro gente que quiere asegurarse un
lugar al que marcharse en caso de que
todo se vaya a pique
y esto es una oportunidad para hacer
presión por ejemplo españa puede poner
sanciones económicas a los oficiales
venezolanos medidas que impedirían este
tipo de movimientos no es nada nuevo es
exactamente lo mismo que se han hecho en
otros casos como corea del norte por
ejemplo este tipo de medidas podrían ser
muy efectivas para poner más presión a
todos estos cargos del ejército para que
pasaran a apoyar a la oposición
democrática
pero ya sé lo que me vais a decir
algunos y qué pasaría si el ejército no
se posiciona a favor de wide o van a
seguir apoyando a un presidente a quien
no reconocen ni en los países vecinos ni
en los eeuu lo cierto es que si lo
cierto es que podríamos vernos en otra
situación de estancamiento perpetuo es
decir que venezuela podría aislarse aún
más y mantener el régimen de maduro
y creedme hay varios precedentes de esto
sin ir más lejos la china de mao tse
tung eeuu no reconocía el gobierno de
beijing para ellos el auténtico gobierno
de china era el de chang kai-chek en
taiwán y esta situación se prolongó
durante varias décadas
otra posibilidad sería una guerra
abierta es decir que maduro lanzara toda
la fuerza de su ejército contra guaidó y
éste tuviera que pedir ayuda
internacional por el momento hay rumores
que somos incapaces de confirmar que
dicen que eeuu estaría mandando tropas a
la frontera de colombia con venezuela
también hay algunas noticias que no sé
cómo son de veraces que dicen que habría
algunos grupos de mercenarios sobre todo
de brasil que estarían llegando a
venezuela para apoyar agua ido por el
momento no sabemos hasta qué punto esto
es cierto son face news o no lo son
apenas hemos tenido tiempo de contrastar
las fuentes pero tendría bastante
sentido que también la oposición se
estuviera preparando para un posible
enfrentamiento con el ejército
[Música]
pero francamente y esta es nuestra
percepción personal es muy difícil que
esto ocurra no parece que eeuu a la
unión europea están dispuestos a
arriesgar tanto y desde luego sería un
escenario malo para todos incluido el
propio maduro veréis las guerras y sobre
todo las guerras civiles son
completamente impredecibles y no sería
la primera vez que un dictador intenta
escapar de su palacio y por el camino le
encuentran unos opositores podéis buscar
la historia de lo que le pasó a benito
mussolini
nicolae ceausescu o muamar el gadafi
dudo mucho que maduro esté dispuesto a
arriesgarse a tener un final parecido
pero todo esto no son más que conjeturas
y por eso turno para ti que crees que va
a pasar en venezuela realmente veremos
una transición democrática
conseguirá aferrarse al poder nicolás
maduro o tal vez una facción de su
propio ejército le termina dando la
espalda podeis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios
y por cierto muchas gracias a gerardo
robledillo de ex patishtán puntocom por
poner las voces en off en este vídeo
expansión.com es una web donde podéis
comparar el coste de vida de distintas
ciudades y como siempre no olvidéis que
publicamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
polític y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]